Ви ж дипломат, так?
Я ніколи не казав, що Зеленський - це миша, а Путін - це кіт.
Що Ви думаєте про Володимира Путіна?
Це такий геній зла, який існує для того, щоб люди розуміли , що таке добро.
Нормандський формат не пасує  Україні?
Бла-бла-бла нічим добрим не закінчиться.
Хто може захистити Україну?
Українці. Хочеш миру, готуйся до війни.
Що відбувається довкола Тристоронньої групи з урегулювання ситуації на Донбасі?
І яке майбутнє мінського процесу та нормандського формату?
Про це ми говоримо з Романом Безсмертним.
Пане Безсмертний, президент Зеленський звільнив Вас
з Тристоронньої групи з урегулювання ситуації на Донбасі.
За що? Адже він сам же вас туди призначив…
Скоріше за все причиною є моя позиція.
А найбільше, я так розумію, що президента, як і його команду,
дратувала не просто позиція, а публічність  цієї позиції,
коли я відкрито для ЗМІ висловлював свою думку.
Але вона не сприймалася в силу того, що ні президент,
ні його оточення не мають відповідного рівня підготовки.
Я завжди мислю таким чином, що як тільки люди переходять на крик,
на емоції або на неадекватні рішення адміністративні,
це означає, що вони просто не розуміють ситуацію. Ось і все.
Ви ж дипломат… Якщо дипломат каже, що нова влада
нічого не розуміє і нічого не вміє?
Ви порівнюєте у цій ситуації Зеленського і Путіна, що Путін
грається із Зеленським , як "кіт з мишею або навіть з мишеням".
Це, мабуть, не дуже дипломатично?
По-перше, я ніколи не казав, що Зеленський - це миша, а Путін - це кіт.
Я казав, що нинішня ситуація нагадує  дуель, гру між тим і тим.
Це вже справа додумування людей, позиціювання тощо.
Але, даруйте, ми живемо у вік емоцій, сучасних комунікацій,
де моя нудна дипломатична мова, даруйте, потрібна тільки мені і дипломатам.
А мені треба донести позицію до людей. І тому
я кажу те, що я кажу, щоб мене розуміли.
Ви так не критикували владу часів екс-президента Порошенка…
Даруйте, я критикував позицію президента Порошенка набагато жорсткіше.
На початку 2016-го я перший казав, що наступив час,
коли на війні почало заробляти політичне керівництво.
Тому ця війна кінця не має.
Чи не ображає Вас заява Офісу президента про те,
що для Тристоронньої групи в Мінську
Леонід Кучма набирає більш ефективних людей?
Якщо в тій чи іншій команді потрібен чи не потрібен
Безсмертний, це, власне, справа того, хто набирає.
Тільки я хочу, щоб ми всі знали: не Леонід Данилович набирає цю команду.
Тобто Леонід Кучма сам особисто немає  впливу на це?
Час покаже, хто набирає команду і хто в ту команду увійде.
Ви заявили, що після загибелі під Павлополем українських військових
Україна мала б призупинити участь у Мінському процесі
до зустрічі в "нормандському форматі". Чому?
Це був режим тиші, в механізмі запровадження якого був пункт покарання
і притягнення до відповідальності тих, хто порушує режим тиші.
Це вперше. Тому що до цього про такі речі взагалі не йшлося.
Але механізму притягнення не виробили.
І тому, коли трапилася ця трагедія, я наполягав на тому,
негайно заявити про вихід з Мінського процесу,
скликання "нормандського формату" і до моменту, поки не буде
покарано тих, хто призвів до порушення режиму тиші.
Коли Україна заявляє про вихід або припинення участі
в Мінському процесі, що в цей момент робить армія?
Армія виконує свої функції, вона воює.
Воює - це не означає, шо наступає чи обороняє.
Це означає, що вона  знаходиться на службі народу, виконує свої функції.
З приводу того, яку позицію займе світ: для України і
політичного керівництва понад усе мають бути інтереси України.
Ці інтереси треба в першу чергу погоджувати із союзниками, якщо такі є.
Вочевидь, чергове "хлібне перемир’я" зривається.
Чи є загроза відновлення широкомасштабних бойових дій на Донбасі?
Вона існує завжди. Окупована частина Донбасу
перенасичена зброєю, боєприпасами, військовою технікою.
За статистикою, наявність техніки більша на цій території,
ніж у багатьох європейських державах, навіть
у таких великих , як Польща, Угорщина тощо.
Ця територія - це не тільки територія і плацдарм для атаки на Україну.
Чи вважаєте ви Мінські угоди мертвими?
Я вважаю, що якщо Мінськ не робити дієвим, то треба пропонувати інший формат.
Те, що так віднеслися до мене зараз, є свідчення того,
що Мінськ і далі буде використовуватися як імітаційний майданчик.
Питання ж не у Вас?
Ні, проблема в тому, що я вимагав чіткості і конструктивності позицій.
На жаль, у відповідь я бачу певну розхолодженість,
млявість у реакції на порушення домовленостей іншою стороною.
Все це свідчить про те, що політичне керівництво не вважає за необхідне
перетворювати Мінськ у дієвий механізм розв’язання проблем.
Ви пропонуєте втекти від тиску Мінських угод
і повністю перейти у "нормандський формат".
Але, по-перше, саме "нормандська четвірка" й розробила Мінські угоди,
а по-друге, "нормандська четвірка" вже три роки, як не зустрічається.
То чим цей формат кращий для України?
Ви ж самі відповіли на питання.
Три роки не збираються, а хочуть, щоб там справа йшла.
То ви ж формуєте завдання і оцінюєте рішення - ну то ви й збирайтеся.
Тому і вимагав: сталася біда, поки не зберетеся - далі не рухаємося.
Я проти брехні в цьому процесі. Тому що вона приводить до трагедії.
Тому або дієвим буде одне, друге, третє, або нащо імітувати все це
і дурити людей, що ось-ось ми вирішимо.
Не вирішимо в такий спосіб.
"Нормандський формат" не пасує  Україні? Чи як?
Будь-який формат пасує, який ухвалює рішення і ці рішення виконуються
А в іншому випадку бла-бла-бла нічим добрим не закінчиться.
Планується, що "нормандська четвірка" зустрінеться у серпні. Ваш прогноз? Що буде?
Якщо вона зустрінеться у серпні, це буде абсолютно безрезультатна зустріч.
Для того, щоб зустріч провести результативно, треба
до того провести зустріч політичних директорів,
потім міністрів закордонних справ, потім глав урядів, лише тоді лідерів.
Якщо попередньої роботи не буде зроблено, а в домовленостях
не буде підписано жодного документу, результативності не буде.
Це рішення мають підписати які країни?
Підписати мають глави урядів, які є сьогодні в "нормандській четвірці".
А якщо пощастить, то там мали би бути і США, і Великобританія , і Китай.
Для того, щоб більше не велася дискусія, що краще
Будапештський меморандум, "нормандський формат" тощо.
Як Ви оцінюєте звільнення Євгена Марчука,
повернення Леоніда Кучми до контактної групи у Мінську.
Це добре чи погано?
Можу сказати, що на статусі, досвіді і знаннях
цих людей і інших Мінський процес і тримається.
Віктор Медведчук бере участь у Мінському процесі?
Ні, після обрання президента Зеленського і виходу указу
про призначення відповідних осіб, Медведчука там жодного разу не було.
У Вас є рецепт повернення українських моряків, політв’язнів і військовополонених?
Щодо моряків рішення міжнародного трибуналу прийняті
і Україна, і світ має просто домогтися виконання рішень.
Всі інші, засуджені по російському законодавству, ті, які знаходяться в Росії.
Є ще люди, які знаходяться в підвалах Луганську та Донецьку.
Їхній статус для України - військовополонені,
а для Росії абсолютно незрозуміло.
Давайте визначимся з тим, що Україна їх вважає військовополоненими,
незаконоутримуваними, бранцями чи ким?
Я їх вважаю військовополоненими.
Але для того, щоб зробити цей крок, треба щоб і Україна
тих, кого вона затримує, бере в полон, визнала військовополоненими.
Президент Зеленський завзято взявся до теми повернення полонених додому.
Чому поки немає якихось результатів?
Я віддаю належне, ціную і підтримую концепцію, яку сповідає  Зеленський.
Вона правильна, з моєї точки зору, що він за пріоритет
бере соціально-гуманітарний блок і тему звільнення полонених.
Правильно. Але треба розуміти, що ти маєш справу з Росією,
яка на чорне каже біле, а на біле чорне.
Це означає, що треба використовувати механізми тиску.
Скажімо, сталася загибель вояків - виходимо з
мінського процесу, запускаємо нормандський.
Чи треба говорити з представниками окупованих територій? В якому форматі? З ким?
Від початку я був переконаний, що головними союзниками України
є громадяни України, які живуть на території
окупованого Донбасу і анексованого Криму.
І це має бути об’єктом, на який має бути спрямована
і гуманітарна, і соціальна політика, в тому числі й
затверджені необхідні програми відселення.
Шостий рік війни - програми відселення немає,
стратегії реінтеграції не існує, стратегії деокупації не існує.
Я дуже радий, що на шостому році війни президентом
нарешті була сформована комісія, яка буде
займатися стратегією реінтеграції.
На шостому році війни.
Як тоді повернути Крим?
Доля майбутнього Криму пов’язана зі статусом
титульної нації кримських татар.
І очевидно, що сьогодні в правовому режимі треба вносити зміни
до Конституції -визнавати Крим Кримськотатарською національною автономію,
Треба відповідні закони, треба формувати уряд Криму.
Парламент Криму на території України.
треба виконувати всі цивільно-правові дії
по відношенню до громадян, які живуть у Криму.
Треба піднімати питання в ООН щодо перспективи і долі Криму.
Я невипадково кажу, що Україні не треба боятися говорити, що
в перспективі Крим має стати державою кримських татар.
Представники України на Мінських перемовинах
не мають ніякого офіційного статусу.
Виходить, що вони такі собі волонтери, котрі
навіть самі оплачують свої подорожі.
Чому так сталося? Як це змінити?
Це не до мене питання. Це питання до
попереднього президента і нинішнього.
Їхній статус змінився лише тим, що за часів попереднього
президента вони брали участь на основі ноти МЗС.
Тепер ці особи призначені указом президента,
але вони не мають ні дипломатичного паспорту,
ні статусу посадових осіб, дипломатів, державних службовців…
Тобто перетин кордону є небезпечним?
Так, небезпечний. Перетин кордону, перевезення документів тощо.
Все це знаходиться за рамками дипломатичного супроводу.
Це питання я підняв під час зустрічі з президентом Зеленським
і отримав доручення про підготовку відповідного указу президента.
Проект такого указу підготовлено.
У разі підписання цього документу особи, які беруть
участь у Мінському процесі, отримують статус.
Ви балотувалися на цих парламентських виборах
Вас перемогли представники "Слуги народу".
Вас звільнили з ТКГ з урегулювання ситуації на Донбасі.
Що Ви збираєтеся робити далі?
Я до цього, зараз і в майбутньому працюватиму викладачем,
читаю три дисципліни, продовжуватиму працювати зі студентами.
У Вас є коротко що сказати президентові Росії Путіну?
Що можна сказати ворогу? З ворогом не говорять.
А президенту Зеленському?
Я би побажав йому досягнення успіхів,
в кінці кінців зрозуміти, що він президент великої нації.
Що Ви вважаєте помилкою президента Порошенка?
Справа не в помилках, а справа в тому, що ціннісні орієнтири
Петра Порошенка далекі від того, щоб такі люди були президентами.
Дякую!